[Music]
my my number one love language was touch
most men yeah most men so
you know
i i you know i i have to be touched
but she trusts me i felt like a king on
the throne that's right that's right
so you love your wife but do you cherish
her find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live it's a show where we
use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today we have on our show again pastor
frank legette thank you so much for
joining us um pastor legette has been in
ministry for over 38 years
yeah but
he's done life coaching for 17 of those
years and he's also into film and
screenwriting so very diverse in the in
the things that he's passionate about
but today he's on the show to talk about
the top three roles that men should
fulfill in their marriages so we have
the two
men here on the show today thank you
scotty and keith
when you think of manhood within
marriage what word singular word comes
to mind
priest
you um okay i'll sorry that you too i'll
throw the question at you when you think
of manhood in marriage well let's let
keith answer and then we'll go to
brittany i don't know and that's tough i
don't i don't know what i would i don't
know i don't like to think about it
what's the word that comes to mind the
first thing that came to mind was
strength but i'm not that strong so i
don't know why i would say that there's
different types of strength
that's true
does the word come to your mind speak of
provision provision same yeah and
protection protection is bad sections
given well i am curious pastor legette
what are the three main roles so i will
just pass it on to you let's start with
the first one
the the very first one that i'm going to
start with and which i believe
um is the one that we all should should
start with men were called to both love
and cherish
our wives
all right love and cherish
now let me say this
and i'm gonna put this disclaimer out
there
on wedding day
most of us
husbands
walk down the aisle we stand before the
preacher before god family and friends
and unfortunately
we don't tell the truth
here's what i mean
the preacher says
do you promise
to love and
cherish
good times and bad sickness and health
for richer for poorer till death
do your part
now here's the point that i make here's
the point that i want to make do you
promise to love not just love
that's not what we responded to the
preacher says do you promise to love and
cherish her
so let me take you to the word of god
because
we were called to do both
not one and leave the and and exclude
the other
so let me take you to the word of god
the apostle paul instructs men that we
should treat our wives
like christ treated his wife
and the apostle paul said christ is the
template he is the example that we
should all follow
so
the question is how did christ treat his
wife ephesians
um 5 25 says husbands love your wives
even as christ also loved the church and
gave himself for
it so we talked about that in the
previous episode okay
now please notice
god does not have to tell
a woman to love her man that is
absolutely positively categorically
without hesitation or equivocation
going to be done by a woman
he tells that to the husband
because that's the message we need to
hear husbands love your wives you ought
to be so christ was the lover christ was
the giver we talked about that in the
previous episode christ was the
sacrificer even though there's no such
word
but i'm making it up here
he's a sacrificer okay
in ephesians 5 29
i'm adding something to the loving the
giving the sacrificing i'm adding
another element of what christ did to
his wife ephesians 5 29 says for no man
ever yet hated his own flesh but listen
to these words but nourishes and
cherishes it even as the lord the church
so what paul is saying is that christ
nourished and cherished his wife the
church so i'm going back christ was the
lover the giver the sacrificer and the
cherisher of his wife
so
so how should we treat our wives
according to the apostle paul we should
love and cherish them not just love them
but love and cherish them and and and
ladies and gentlemen let me explain to
you there is a huge difference between
the two
and the problem is
many men love their wives
but fail to cherish them the way the
woman
wants to be loved and cherished there is
a difference
see see see and the problem is that
loving
a man loving his wife can be oh so
selfish
how do i know that
because i was selfish in my own love
see for for most of us the husbands in
the relationship
the relationship is all about us
all right it's what we do is what we
want to do is what we want to spend so
so the marriage really becomes all about
us
uh even though we love our wives i'll
give you an example my own personal
experience
my wife wanted us next year this year
this year would have been our if she had
lived um she passed away september 3rd
of last year to covert and she wanted us
to
repeat our vows for our 30th anniversary
and i said why
you know i'm working she's not she's
retired right you're right i get up i
get up at the crack of dawn she gets up
at the crack at noon i'm the one that's
working i'm bringing in all the money
and i'm saying
why
why do we look i love you i'm never
gonna have another woman why do i need
to go through all of that expense
because she wanted it that's why
that's cherishing
loving and cherishing
loving can sometimes be all about us but
cherishing will be all about our partner
i praise god
that both that that before she passed
i graduated
from loving exclusively to loving and
cherishing and when she said it when she
said it is it we i said baby when you
come out of here
we
we're renewing our vows i don't care
what it costs she called me from the
hospital and said frank when i come home
i'm not coming home to that bed i want
that one of those sleep number bits i
said baby when you get home it will be
right here in the room
because i had graduated from loving
exclusively to loving and cherishing i
had graduated from life being about me
and my marriage and relationship being
about me to my marriage and relationship
that my number one goal and objective
aside from pleasing christ
which is number one which was pleasing
my wife
i graduated and my love and and our
relationship went into the stratosphere
it went into the stratosphere
and i wish i had gotten this so much
sooner so number one loving and
cherishing our wives okay
yeah i can
i can get on a roll yeah i know i love
it preach preach i'm listening we're
just listening we're soaking it in
so um i i like the aspect that you're
bringing up right here about cherishing
because you think about the simple
um
idea if you have something that you
really are into you really like you
really are gonna take care of that you
really it's like the object of your
affection you know
um and i like that you brought up the
the the idea that if you love something
that always necessarily i mean love you
can love lots of different things but
for your own self-gratification
the real definition of love is god gave
himself uh you know for the the people
he he gave everything that's that's the
definition of love is um and and our
world is is really mixed up this concept
and they've they've really sold us
lust which is taking something from
someone i want you to gratify me rather
than what can i do to gratify you and i
think that that object of cherish really
brings that concept out so i really i
really appreciate how you kind of
highlighted that
i think another thing is um
someone might hear that and be like wow
so i need to cater to all of my wife's
materialistic needs and things like that
but i think the beauty and protection is
that
when a woman is connected to christ her
desires will change her desires will be
one that is probably towards her
household and more balanced not
materialistic so it should be the
husband's joy to meet those needs
because it would be good needs it would
be ones that god has placed in her heart
okay pastor legette second the second
role that men should fulfill in their
marriage
it took me 37 years before i really
really
began to understand this next point and
to begin to preach it um
and
really my my numbers are off because i
started doing this a little while ago
but it the impact of this is really
hitting me point number two
second role
men were called to be the saviors
of their wives in particularly
on a physiological
level
let me explain
when christ walked to earth for three
night and particularly during his
ministry three and a half years
what did he do more than anything else
healed people
he healed he didn't preaching was not
his number one he healed he healed the
sick and the afflicted bodies of all
those who came to him he was healing his
wife from sun up to sundown every single
day
why
because the text says
ephesians 5 23 for the husband is the
head of the wife even as christ is is
the head of the church and he is the
savior
of the body
so
so christ came and he healed and healed
and healed and healed now paul says that
christ is the example now can we do
exactly what he did with all of those
miracles no but but on an emotional
level
is saying yes christ is still the
template
paul is saying that it is the role of
the husbands
to protect and save our wives bodies
from life-threatening illness and
disease how why
here's why proverbs 17 22
a merry heart does good like a medicine
but a broken spirit dries the bones
and what paul is trying to inform us
and tell us and instruct us is
is that we husbands were to love our
wives so deeply that their bodies were
insulated from disease
because when a woman is not loved when
she has a broken heart and a broken
spirit it cracks open a door to
life-threatening illness and disease
because women when they're hurt they get
that that that hurt goes into the core
of their bodies
and their bodies begin to secrete two
hormones when the human brain perceives
a threat
be it be it physical or emotional the
brain begins to secrete chemicals or
hormones called adrenaline
and cortisol
and when those things and when she's not
happy she's not loved she's physically
emotionally verbally sexually um abused
her body secretes that hormone over and
over and over and over and over again
and one doctor says it's like pouring
acid inside the body internally
that's the that's the devastating effect
that it has
on
her organs internally and so i know this
to be a fact in a few years ago some of
my friends three four of my friends
wives began to die
the death certificate said
cancer
but because i had talked to them because
i spent time with them privately and
because they shared with me that the
husbands were either cheating on them or
were incredibly insensitive to their
knee and didn't love them the way they
wanted to be loved it cracked open the
door to life-threatening illness and
cancer walked in the door and took my
friends out wow
in my sermon on my youtube page my frank
elegant the third youtube page i did a
series as a result it's entitled you
make me sick parts one two and three and
the subtitle is the nexus between a
woman's broken heart and
life-threatening illness and disease and
i lay out the case
scientifically having done my homework
in research
that when a woman has a broken heart and
a broken spirit it cracks open the door
to life-threatening illness and disease
that's why medical science says one out
of every two women will die from a heart
attack
because when she's not loved
a woman a woman a woman can't perceive
the concept of not being loved
and so and so and so cancer cancer
and ms did you know that 60
6 out of every 10
ms patients are women
these are issues that takes place when a
woman has a broken heart and a broken
and a broken spirit but my favorite
author my favorite author says this that
a husband can insulate his wife against
these kinds of diseases in the book
adventist home pages 217 paragraph three
she says this i'm going to read it for
you
she says the husband should manifest
great interest in his family
especially should he be very tender of
the feelings of a feeble wife
kind cheerful and encouraging words will
prove more effective than the most
listen to this than the most healing
medicines i'm gonna repeat that
kind cheerful and encouraging words will
prove more effective than the most
healing medicines
these will bring courage to the heart of
the desponding and discouraged and the
happiness and sunshine brought into the
family by kind acts and in church and
encouraging words will repay the effort
tenfold the husband should manifest
great interest because he can be
um
he can he should be a vera tender of the
feelings of a feeble wife he can shut
the door
against much disease says my favorite
officer
so how is that possible it's possible
because of ephesians 5 23 for the
husband is the heavenly wife even as
christ is the head of the church and he
is the husband is the is the savior of
the body
in another place
ministry of healing my favorite author
says the love which which christ
diffuses through the whole body whole
being is a vitalizing power
every vital part the brain the heart the
nerves it touches with healing
that's what a man's love is supposed to
do for his wife a man's love is supposed
to bathe herself in such love
that disease bounces off her
and insulate her and insulates her from
disease
it's powerful ladies and gentlemen
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
that's powerful
you know do you do you think that
i just i i just see as i'm listening to
you talk about this kind of stuff it's
very interesting to me that you women
wear things like little hearts on you
all the time
as if like it's like a little subtle
like thing of just love me love me love
me and it's like to keep you know the
focus the males do
generally pursue you know
that that that's very interesting that
that's just how god designed it how he
set it up and and how you know if we
really do give that affection
that you know i mean it can have some
actual real scientific evidence yeah uh
there's a book that's written that says
a lot of i wish i knew what it was off
the top of my head but it talked about a
lot of the diseases that we have are
actually connected to um various
emotional issues it like anger produces
a an actual effect in like your stomach
or i can't remember what it is i might
be totally speaking out of line here but
no you're actually right um um dr w lee
cowden
and i thought to put that in but i i
decided not to all of that information
is on my frankie la get the third
youtube channel uh you make me sick part
one dr w lee cowden makes the connection
that when there's prolonged anger yeah
it's like a heart attack your liver
you're gonna take out your liver
prolonged prolonged um disappointment
and rejection um um it has a deleterious
effect on specific body parts yeah yeah
i remember reading that scientific fact
and so when a woman when a woman she
when she comes home to a toxic
relationship and marriage every single
day her body is secreting these hormones
and these hormones is like and they
never get turned off it's like it's like
a spigot that can't turn off and the
water just runs constantly it's the
doctor dr gabor mate says it's like
taking acid it's like drinking acid in
the body wow i'm wondering if this is a
an exchange or if it's really just um
the man really being in a position of
power and really influencing uh the wife
on a physiological level or is it that
in the act of giving that love which is
protecting the woman physically that
it's also doing the same to the man
is it is there a deficit within a man if
he's not giving the love he should be
giving to his wife
i don't know i don't know i i haven't i
haven't in any of my research
seen any
physiological
effect of us not
loving our wives the way that we should
i know that it will impact the marriage
and the relationship
i yeah i think it's like it takes two
right um one thing that that a male is
seeking for is you know that that
validation and that physical um that
physical confirmation that uh you know
this person is loving me and and it's
that physical touch that really relays
that information um and so i think when
you break down one of those
he's now not giving the woman what she
wants which her natural response is to
give the man what he wants and i think
the whole thing could break down from
that point
absolutely absolutely and so
and you know
my wife
taught me
that if my needs are not met i cannot
meet your needs it's a two-way street
you know dr gary chapman has an
excellent book out the five love
languages that many of us know about
um my my number one love language was
touch mm-hmm
you know
i i you know i i have to be touched
but she trusts me i felt like a king on
the throne that's right that's right
but but if i wasn't meeting her needs
and my need was
went unmet right
and oftentimes
and often time in a relationship one
will withhold which makes the other
withhold as well
and it just you know it's like there has
to be a symbiotic relationship there
where and and that is the very
definition of love right both try to out
give each other you know absolutely and
i think it's i think it's like uh you
know it's just more than just physical
touch as well i know my wife likes to
make food because i like that food and
i've heard that children will like the
food that the father eats i mean that's
it's like this really interesting um
relationship just even even in that way
the woman's you know giving to the man
by by making him the food that he wants
and and it's very interesting not always
i'll preference that i smell because
there's a debate like when the man comes
home and everyone sits down at the table
who should the woman serve first the man
or the children have you heard that
debate before
i let the children i let the children
eat i wondered like from what you're
saying should you feed the man first so
the children see that the man enjoys the
food and then they eat all their anyway
let's go back to you look at i actually
oh go ahead yeah so what is what do you
think is the number one
thing that makes a man feel like a
failure
like is there something like how god
designed us or designed them
and if they cannot fulfill that in their
own life whether it is marriage or
something else
what is that
um there are there are a number of
roles that god has required these are
not optional there are a number of roads
that god has required us to fulfill
and they all come out of the garden okay
um in another presentation i do i show
that they all come out of the garden of
eden
um and so
for the average man
if he's not fulfilling those roles
um if he can't if he can't and i'm gonna
skip the one that i'm talking about next
but if but if if if if he is incapable
for whatever reason of being the
provider for his family
um let's say let's say he gets injured
um and the injury
is permanent
and so now
the wife has to switch roles with him
and be the provider for the family
because his income decreases he's not
making as much he's on uh disability
in spite of the fact that everybody
understands you know somebody he was in
a car somebody ran through a stop
lightning everybody understands all
right dad dad husband it's not your
fault
our manhood will take a beating
because we know
that there is a speci there are specific
roles that god has called us to and the
average man when he's especially when
he's attuned to the voice of god
when we are not fulfilling those roles
we
we we
we we have this emotional thing that we
go through because we know we're not
doing it and we know we should do it and
it's the spirit of god also that's
talking to us but if if if we are
incapacitated for a specific reason
that still happens because we want to be
the providers and the protectors and the
burden bearers for our families we want
to be all of that the average man
um and so if we're not doing that
man our manhood can take a beating and
on the physiological level
as a guy
let's say he has some issues
um as he ages as often is the case and
now
um
ed
erectile dysfunction
is a multi-million dollar industry
because sexually he can't perform and
satisfy his wife he will take a beating
emotionally and mentally
because he he's in uh unable
to fulfill that role now some of the
problems may be stuff that he's induced
because of a poor diet and lifestyle
but nevertheless
if he's not fulfilling those roles
we are we we
we will suffer we will suffer some
consequences emotionally
you know i i see the relationship
um between a husband and a wife very
similar to um like god is our provider
so i see these very much so parallels i
mean he should be our everything he's
the one that you know is is our
fulfillment our satisfaction our are our
you know everything and in a in a mini
micro version of that is our role with
our families and it's kind of
paralleling this greater spiritual truth
that i see and i mean can you imagine if
god couldn't fulfill um you know taking
care of you or god couldn't fulfill
satisfying you or any of those um you
know that's that's a that's a that's a a
recipe for you know uh uh you wouldn't
trust him yeah wouldn't trust him yeah
so i think that that's why
god set this up like that so that we
have these relationships so that we can
go oh i can understand this physical
relationship that i have here but it
really is is is giving me a picture of
god and i've i've met so many people if
you have a really messed up view of your
dad
it's really messing with your view of
god
god determined
that that that there are specific roles
i have a whole message on it
the nine required roles of a godly man
god determined that we have our roles
and our wives have their roles and
they're not interchangeable
and god determined that we should
function in every one of these roles and
if the garden of eden has taught us
anything
you cannot violate
the word of god
without suffering consequences i don't
care how we try to justify it
rationalize it it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what society is saying
god has set up a blueprint
for relational and marital happiness it
comes out of the garden there are two
blueprints that come out of the garden
of eden
the god's blueprint is is in genesis one
and two there's a satanic blueprint
that's in genesis 3.
everything that god established in
genesis 1 and 2 satan reverses in
genesis 3 everything
and the world
is living out of genesis 3 and even many
in the adventist church and christian
churches are living out of genesis 3 and
fail to understand it
so
god provided man
genesis 2 15 he put him in the garden
the word of god says to to uh how to how
to to work it and uh and i'm not quoting
verbatim but but but to work it and to
keep it
god gave adam a job
and i love it that he gave his job was
to keep food on the table yeah i love it
that he gave he gave him a job he gave
him some parameters but within those
parameters he was still giving adam the
dominion to to make it and create it
like you see fit he didn't say you have
to trim this bush like that and you
gotta do this he didn't give him this
shopping list he he said here's the
responsibilities that you have and i
think the the responsibilities between a
man and a woman the man
has different responsibilities like like
what you're saying i like that you kind
of broke that up
whenever you read in the in the bible
the example of the female um
jesus's mother she's the one that read
him all those stories she's the one that
that brought to uh him daily all those
little things right um joseph's role was
different than that a lot of times you
hear it's the mother that's put all
those little like things in there but
really the imprint of the character
comes from the father and so you know at
some point that father figure has this
major stamp on the child and the mother
has a has an influence on the child's
upbringing as well but they're different
than those two
and so um you know i think when we kind
of begin to understand the model that
god put up we can kind of work backwards
from there and say well look at our
modern society they're trying to flip
that around like what you said satan
understands that that's the model that
god created so now i'm going to take the
woman out of the home especially during
those formative years of the child send
her to work and then put the man there
which we aren't built for that nurturing
and that that installation of the love
and the caring and that i mean that
that's that that comes from the woman
and the man comes you know the the the
understanding of the principle and the
the duty and the you know those kind of
things so the child needs both of those
uh you know but they're totally
different roles
yeah now
in the african-american community i've
read studies that says this
that over 70
of children in the african-american
community grow up in a home without a
father
of hispanic children
and only 8 of caucasian children grow up
without a father wow god determined
that every family
needs a
father and a mother
because children
get something from each of them
the son looks at his father and gets a
picture of the kind of husband and
father he needs to be
when he gets his family
he looks at his mother and gets a
picture of the kind of wife and mother
he ought to be looking for to establish
his own family with the daughter looks
at her dad and gets a picture of the
kind of husband and father she ought to
be looking for when she settles down and
establishes her family and she looks at
her mom and she gets a picture of the
kind of wife and mother she needs to be
when one of those is missing in an
african american community
by and large it is the father you're
having husbands who are coming into the
relationship and he has one half of the
picture that he needs to be that whole
person is missing and so i teach the
women you must teach him how to love you
the way you want to be loved because he
doesn't know how to do that because he
hasn't seen that pit he hasn't grown up
with that picture
and so i teach them how to teach their
man to love them on her terms and not
his and sometimes that is a difficult
concept for women to achieve because she
expects him to be there
but but but
you can't do
quite often we're not going to do what
we've not seen he has no model we can't
do what we don't know yeah so
and so i have to educate these women on
how to do that go ahead so do you think
that can be a dangerous mentality
because a lot of women also
a lot of women also
um pick men because of their potential
and so when you're saying you have to
teach your man how to love you you can
easily see a man who didn't grow up with
a father
maybe his life has been really hard you
just want to nurture and love him but
then he doesn't step up to those
responsibilities so do you think that
could be like
a gray area i guess that's why people
come to me that's why this process has
to start in the dating phase
because what needs to happen what needs
to happen and i'll talk about this in
the previous episode
i helped to put women in the driver's
seat in the relationship and at some
point
they have to stop the vehicle
and on there needs to be a graduation
because he needs to then take over the
driver's seat because scripture says
husbands you are the head
all right
so there needs to be a graduation they
need to switch places at some point but
not until he has demonstrated
that he knows how to be the head of his
home a husband a father a priest a
provider a protector a burden bearer a
lover and a cherisher and and a savior
to her wife to his wife when he has
demonstrated all of that or if he is
deficient in any of those areas is he
willing to go to work to improve himself
in those areas once he's demonstrated
that it is then okay for her to go
forward and start and start and start
planning but he if he's not willing to
fulfill those roles
i'm guaranteeing you you're going to
have issues and if you want to have
issues then just go forward to wedding
day with that mindset because they're
coming so it's it's like this too um you
know he gets the love aspect from the
mom right but he gets the the judgment
and the the the duty and those things
from the dad and and i i don't know i
kind of see it as like you know even in
in god he's as a judgmental as he is
loving he can give you mercy at the same
time he can condemn you and when those
two things are preached together we see
a more full picture of god like there's
rules and things that we need to live by
you can't just be like well love
everybody and do whatever you want those
two concepts don't don't
separate and in the home that's really
how he set up the home the mother is
instilling this love and this compassion
and all these elements and the father's
instilling the duty and i must do this
because it's it's what i should do and
think about like going all the way back
to the garden of eden what broke down
she got swayed by the emotions of things
because satan understood how he
understands god the most so he
understands how eve was built eve is
built for love she's built for emotion
so he appealed to her emotion and all of
a sudden
what what adam should have done duty
my duty is to my god he broke down in
that thing so he was able to capture
both those people using different
tactics i think if satan would have come
straight to the man first it probably
would have been a different result
because he was built for duty i'm gonna
do this and god told me not to so i'm
gonna do it and so like you know those
two concepts i think is what a child is
actually getting from having both
parents and yeah like you said pastor
it's going to be more difficult if one
of those components is not there it's
not impossible but you're going to have
to really like you know
be creative with how you actually
instill those concepts into them
yeah
i mean god god determined that a man
should be a man and her husband should
be in the family for a reason that's
right
we represent god in the family and when
you when you talk to many children who
have turned their backs on god
it is often connected to the fact that
their fathers were derelict yeah
and they view god like that like he's
just out in space and he's not here yeah
we're the god figures in the home that's
right we're the god figures in the home
yeah
so for the first role it's for the man
to love and cherish
the second it's to be the wife's savior
in a physic physiological sense
what is the third role that men should
fulfill in their marriage
the the priest and the spiritual leader
of his home and family no ifs no ends no
but
i didn't understand
why until i i started working on on on
on on this on on this message i didn't
understand why god
did not just save himself some time
and create adam and eve simultaneously
he could have yeah he chose not to
here's why
there's several principles when you when
you open up the book of genesis there's
several principles that jump out at you
immediately
and one of them
is the principle of spiritual intimacy
with god
for the for the husband and the father
and so and so rather than
create eve
simultaneously with adam
knowing that god would not have had
adam's attention
god creates adam first
and he spends the better part of the day
with him
and in that time frame god is the father
and adam is the son and god is pouring
into adam and god is saying to adam adam
when you get your family you need to you
need to spend time with me first because
you cannot give what you do not have
so you need to get up early and spend
time with me and i will pour into you
and then you'll get your family up and
then you will pour into them and even
though it was a matter of hours you need
to understand the impact of the
intellect of adam
was a hundred times greater than ours
and and god taught it and adam caught it
and it is the fact of life
that is soon and and and so class was
open all day long and god was teaching
him
and as soon as eve came along class was
over
because homeboy had eyes on one thing
and that was that gorgeous woman that
was created just for him
god is absolutely brilliant yeah yeah
so so adam so so so my favorite author
says that
adam was the priest of his home but he
was also the priest and the spiritual
leader of the entire planet yeah yeah he
was captain he was designated the son of
god and when when the sons of god which
was the male first created males on all
the planets met with god
adam initially was there the spiritual
leader of the planet so if he's the
spiritual leader of the planet he
certainly is the priest and spiritual
leader of of of his tone
that's the role that god has called us
to
so what does that look like is that just
gathering the family together to worship
a couple times a week and boom you're
the the spiritual leader of the home
what can you give us
some practicality to that
role
when covet hit
um we shut out my last service was march
14 2020
and
in april
i called i called my family together
called my kids together they're all
grown some of them have their own
families
i said look
we were all caught
we were all caught with our pants down
because nobody saw this coming
i said guess what
it's never going to happen to us ever
again
said every monday night at nine o'clock
we're gonna get on the zoom and we're
gonna put plans together
and we're going to prepare
for
common trouble and that which is coming
down the road so every monday night we
were just on last night every monday
night we're coming together we're
talking about buying property because
everybody is leaving where they live
from where they live and we're all gonna
purchase property and we're all gonna uh
build something i don't know if it's
tiny houses or or what we're gonna do
but we're all gonna be on one property
we're talking about buying our seeds and
guess what they're all grown
but i'm the priest and i'm the spiritual
leader of my family they look to me for
spiritual guidance and direction
because i'm the spiritual leader of the
family and everybody knows it and that's
the role that i should function in even
though they're all grown with their own
children they've looked at me for
guidance and direction and that's how it
should be
so i said here we go here's where we're
going follow me as i follow christ
and the end they all fall in line
can i add something to that
what really is a role of a priest for
his church
i mean really what does he care about
the rest of the people in that room
he could be doing this whatever he wants
with his time right but he has a love
for those people and he wants to see
them saved and the object of the priest
i see is the person that's like my job
is to help you get a connection with god
so that you will make it to the kingdom
and i believe that that is the main role
that of your family as you are uh you
know raising them you raise them to have
a love for god you raise them with the
principles of duty how you wake up early
in the morning and seek god first and
his righteousness so that all the other
things in life will be coming second
place to to that relationship
um all of those things are are what a
priest is really trying to do in a
bigger sense so you know once again you
have this micro version
of of a greater concept which is really
how a priest in a church operates or a
pastor in a church which is a greater
explanation of how jesus is with with
the world people
as priests we are the we are the
spiritual leaders
we say here's the word
let's follow the word let's be in
harmony with the word
and and we're shepherds
so if someone goes astray we've got it
we've got to go get them and we've got
to lead them back to the straight and
narrow i don't care if they're older
than i am i've got i've got members who
are older than i here's the standard all
right you cannot do this and be saved in
god's kingdom all right we need to get
back over here
um we've got to always be uplifting the
word of god it is our safeguard it's not
about what i think
you know you don't need to be concerned
you need to be concerned about what he
thinks
in his word here's the word let's follow
the word and we need to be continually
pointing our church family and my in our
biological families to the word of god
so when my children go to go to the left
she said come on no no no no baby you
can't do this i just had a conversation
with a family member come on uh uh-uh
uh-uh here's the standard here's the
standard all right you gotta you gotta
you gotta abide by the word of god
so
that's our role that's our
responsibilities to lead them to christ
to lead them to the kingdom and
sometimes those conversations
are difficult
especially when you're dealing with with
with adults
they're difficult
but but when you've established yourself
as the priest and the leader and they
love you and they respect you you can
have those difficult conversations
and they will hear you they may not
always abide immediately but they will
hear you because you put the time in
well thank you so much pastor laguette
and um you know a lot was shared here in
this short episode today but pastor
lagette has so much more information on
his youtube channel frank e legette iii
and those links will be in the
description box below
you know none of what we discussed here
especially towards men is easy we're not
saying that this is going to be a walk
in the park but i encourage you men
watching to draw support from jesus from
god your heavenly father and also to
draw support from your community your
church but also the little ice studios
community down in this comment section
below
we encourage you to comment and we will
do our best to interact with you as well
pastor leget's information will be in
the description box as well so if you
enjoyed this episode please like and
subscribe share this video to someone
else and we will see you next time on
led live thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you